cette marche blanche en hommage à ce
jeune Thomas tué samedi dernier lors
d'une d'une attaque d'une agression au
cours d'une soirée festive je suis avec
Rosen morga envoyé spécial du Figaro
depuis 3 jours ici Rosen beaucoup de
monde aujourd'hui pour cette cette
marche blanche cet hommage oui oui
beaucoup de monde beaucoup de monde
parce que elle était très attendue cette
marche je pense depuis 4 jours que que
le drame a eu lieu dans cette dans cette
fête de village à crépool qui a un
village à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
roman suriser et beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de gens de l'équipe de rugby de
Thomas parce que Thomas était au RC
roman beaucoup de lycéens aussi on est
devant le lycée du Dauphiné où il était
scolarisé en
terminale des membres de sa famille
aussi qu'on a aperçu un petit peu au
début de la marche qui est en train de
commencer à à s'élancer jusqu'au RC
roman qui est aussi dans roman sur iser
voilà c'est il y a des pancartes il y a
des t-shirts en hommage à à Thomas qui a
été poignardé à mort samedi soir et et
beaucoup d'émotions beaucoup d'émotions
effectivement on a vu ses pancartes on a
vu vu certaines personnes qui sont
venues avec des des fleurs blanches
c'est ce que vous ont dit les les gens
que vous avez rencontrés vous êtes ici
depuis lundi que vous disent les gens
ici notamment sur la personnalité de ce
de ce jeune homme de ce Thomas bah on
nous raconte que c'était un garçon très
gentil sans histoire très aimable avec
un grand sourire d'ailleurs on le voit
sur la photo que le RC roman a publié de
lui sur son compte facebook pas du tout
dans des histoires de bande ou de trafic
quelconque c'était un jeune un jeune
bien sans histoire avec des parents avec
deux frères aînés qui sont aussi
présents
aujourd'hui et voilà tout ce qui a de
plus normal quoi un mot sur l'enquête
également Rosen parce que c'est aussi ça
maintenant ce qui est important c'est
déterminer d'abord qui sont les auteur
de de cette agression est-ce que l'on a
une idée un petit peu plus précise
maintenant de ce qui s'est déroulé
samedi dernier et puis surtout des
auteur de cet acte alors on a récemment
reçu donc des des informations du
parquet de Valence qui nous nous en a
donné hier soir de nouvelles nous
informant que neuf personnes avaient été
interpellées SEP aux alentours de
Toulouse de dans roman sur iser pour
l'instant on a très peu d'informations
sur les profils de ces personnes on sait
pas exactement d'où elles viennent dans
romans sur isire on sait que l'auteur
principal du enfin du coup de poignard
qui a tué thomas lui est âgé de 20 ans
il est nationalité française il résidait
dans le centre de roman sur iser avec sa
mère qui elle aussi est de nationalité
française et il se trouvait à bord d'une
voiture avec cise autes personnes si
autres suspects quand ils ont été
interpellés par le GIGN hier dans
l'après-midi qu'est-ce que l'on sait
Rosen précisément sur ce qu'il s'est
passé dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
d'abord est-ce que Thomas et ses amis
ont été directement visés par par les
agresseurs alors tout est très flou
encore à ce stade parce que le parquet
est très
prudent on sait qu'il y a eu un incident
entre un vigile et un individu qui était
extérieur à la soirée que de cet
incident a commencé une bagare
généralisée avec euh avec des armes
blanches puisque cette cet individu à
l'extérieur de la soirée était
accompagné par une dizaine d'autres
individus qui eux étaient armés et que
des invités de la soirée venant prêter
mains forte au vigiles qui se faisaient
un peu dépasser par la situation euh se
sont retrouvés dans cette dans cette
expédition punitive vengeresse c'est
comme ça que le parquet qualifie
qualifie l'incident et non pas de Rix
comme on a pu l'entendre au début
euh voilà c'est ce qu'on sait pour
l'instant c'est très flou
euh les les témoins de qui étaient
présents à la soirée pour l'instant par
le peu parce que la gendarmerie est
encore en train de faire son enquête
donc ils ont un devoir de de discrétion
et de silence est-ce que vous avez pu
rencontrer peut-être certains certains
témoins j'ai pu rencontrer des proches
de personnes qui étaient présente à la
soirée oui ouis ouais qui me raconte du
coup la violence de la violence inouï de
de de cette agression le une embrouille
qui aurait complètement dérapé et qui me
raconte surtout le choc de la famille de
de Thomas euh qui vient d'un village non
loin de crpol et de T de tous ses amis
qui étaient présents à la soirée ouais
merci beaucoup Rosen morga en voyer
spécial du du du Figaro alors que la
marche vient de de commencer à l'instant
vous le voyez certainement sur ces
images beaucoup beaucoup de monde
plusieurs centaines de de personnes ici
cet après-midi merci beaucoup Rosen
votre compte-rendu écrit qui est bien
sûr à retrouver d'ici quelques heures
sur le
Figaro.fr et merci beaucoup Timothé
d'être en direct avec nous depuis roman
surizer vous l'avez av dit cette marche
en hommage à Thomas on peut regarder
d'ailleurs on a d'autres images en ce
moment du début de cette marche avec des
gens qui qui qui marche avec avec des
T-Shirts en hommage à à Thomas repose en
paix et nous allons parler de ce sujet
aujourd'hui je suis avec Antoine
Valentin bonjour Antoine merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes mère divver droite
de saint-joir en haut de Savoie vous
êtes mère d'un d'un petit village comme
c'est le cas pour pour crpol on va
sans parler de de de de de cette ce
sujet précis mais cette problématique
finalement que vous vous connaissez bien
est-ce que déjà ça vous surprend que
quelque chose comme ça arrive
malheureusement ça ne me surprend pas
pour deux raisons d'abord c'est un
ensuvagement généralisé de notre société
qui touche aussi les territoires ruraux
et puis surtout parce que nos
territoires sont dépourvus d'une
présence importante de force de l'ordre
de gendarme quand il y a à Paris un
gendarme Un policier pour 350 habitants
il y en a un pour 1700 1800 habitants
dans mon territoire donc ce sont des des
des déserts de sécurité qui sont
propices au développement de
l'insécurité de la délinquence de la
criminalité est très propice à ce genre
d'expédition pulitive de rasia
criminelle et donc non je ne suis pas
surpris et je suis évidemment en tant
qu'élu local très ému par cette
situation qui pourrait toucher tous les
villages ruraux de France qui est
insupportable on s'habitue trop souvent
avec cette actualité à des faits
barbares chaque semaine ici un
enseignant aujourd'hui un jeune jeune et
on oublie que derrière le fait d'hiver
et bien il y a un frère un fils un
cousin et des drames horribles pour des
familles qui emporteront cette peine
pour l'éternité est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce que cette cette violence dans les
dans les dans les petites villes vous
vous l'avez vu augmenter exploser
écoutez c'est pas moi qui l'AV augmenté
c'est même les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur on se rend compte que la
délinquence explose dans les territoires
ruraux quand elle commence seulement à
être jugulée en zone police donc oui il
y a une délinquence et une violence
globale qui se développe et face à ça
nos territoires ne sont pas armés et
pour autant vous le voyez cette ce petit
bal de village dans un village de 500
habitants et bien les élus avaient eu
recours à un agent de sécurité un vigile
qui l'aurait imaginé il y a encore
quelques années moi je suis pas très
vieux il y a encore pas si longtemps que
ça les gendarmes dans ma commune ils
étaient en chemisette avec un pantalon
de ville et des chaussures de ville
aujourd'hui ils ne sortent pas à
l'extérieur sans un gilet par bal
porte-plaque qui est censé les protéger
de tir à l'arme de guerre donc c'est en
dilon sur notre société sur ses dérives
et elle touche évidemment aussi nos
territoire oui vous voyez cette cette
insécurité qui qui grandit aussi dans
dans les petits villages comme le vre
bien sûr et
puis les déserts de sécurité attirent
les les délinquants la nature à horreur
du vide et les délinquants et les
criminels aussi donc moi j'ai vu de
façon très concrète en début de mandat
ma commune squatterée par des des jeunes
et et dans le lot des jeunes délinquants
qui qui étaient venu monter des points
d'î dans mon village parce que c'était
bien plus facile de le faire ici que
dans le quartier de reconquête
républicaine à 20 km où les forces de
l'ordre sont bien plus présentes et où
il y a une délinquence qui est bien plus
installée et donc une concurrence entre
les délinquants j'ai même eu un un
réseau de trafiquants de stupéfiants
albanais venu volontairement s'installer
dans mon territoire pour ces
caractéristiqu plus facile oui c'est
quelque chose que que vous voyez c'est
le fait que vous le disez tout à l'heure
dans les les grandes villes il y a plus
de gendarmes par rapport à la population
vous aujourd'hui vous demandez plus
d'effectifs on imagine bien sûr on se
rend compte qu'il y a deux types de
citoyens il y a ceux qui bénéficient des
politiques publiques et puis il y a ces
citoyens oubliés et c'est notamment ceux
qui manifestent aujourd'hui c'est eu ces
Français modestes besogneux qui payent
leurs impôts qui font prévaloir leurs
droits après leurs devoirs qui passent
souvent sous les radars médiatiques
parce qu'à l'issue de cette marche il
n'y aura certainement pas de voiture
brûlées ni d'émeutes il n'y a d'ailleurs
pas de député de la France soumise pas
d'acteur ou de sportifs connus c'est
cette France oubliée cette France des
territoires et c'est et c'est j'imagine
ça que vous que vous regrettez est-ce
que selon vous il y a une nouvelle
typologie de délinquence justement je ne
sais pas s'il y a une nouvelle typologie
délinquence je crois qu'il y a désormais
une délinquence qui est
débridée notre société toute entière est
bâtie sur le respect fondamentale de la
vie humaine et ces délinquants venant
faire cette rasia punitive ont marqué
non seulement que ils étaient les
nouveaux maîtres de ces territoires
qu'il méprisaient l'ordre républicain
qu'il méprisaient la loi mais surtout
qu'il méprisaient la vie et c'est une
barbarie qui qui est insupportable et
qui est sans commune mesure avec ce que
l'on a pu connaître jusqu'à présent il
est même à se demander si des gendarmes
avaient pu rapidement intervenir
qu'aurait fait deux gendarmes dans une
petite fourgonnette face à cet orde de
10 ou ou 15 agresseurs armés d'armes
blanches dans ce petit village c'est
d'une gravité confondante pour pour
revenir à à votre village à à à à
saint-joire jeai je l'ai noté ici euh
pour pour pourevenenir à votre à votre
village euh comment ça se passe au
niveau de la sécurité vous vous avez vu
les effectifs de sécurité diminuer petit
à petit alors d'abord moi ma gendarmerie
n'accueille plus de public depuis des
années et puis elle a été mutualisée
avec une autre gendarmerie un peu plus
loin ce qui d'ailleurs rend très
difficile le dépôt de plainte en tout
cas le le la constatation des fait de
justice ce qui permet d'ailleurs de
sortir des statistiques qui sont plutôt
décorréé de la réalité mais oui donc on
voit une population qui croit une
délinquence qui augmente qui se durcifi
et puis des effectifs qui stignent voir
qui baissent pendant une partie de l'été
il y avait des postes vacants dans ma
gendarmerie et donc c'est nos
collectivités avec leur faible moyens
qui doivent malheureusement paser à ce
désengagement de l'État on l'a fait
notamment en embauchant deux policiers
municipaux qui sont armé qui travaillent
la nuit les weekends en installant une
cinquantaine de caméras mais ce n'est
pas chose aisée avec nos budgets qui
sont malheureusement à la baisse oui
parce que les les les dotations de
l'État ont ont ont ont baissé n'ont pas
baissé elles ont fondu drastiquement
elles sont en en réduction permanente
quand nos compétences elles sont chaque
jour plus étendues là la sécurité
ailleurs le remplacement d'un service
public et cetera et cetera nous sommes
les couteaux suisses de la République
les maires les commune et nous nous
retrouvons à faire face à des
compétences qui sont pourtant des
compétences régaliennes et c'est une
vraie problématique de société oui en ce
moment il y a la il y a le le le Congrès
de l'Association des maires de France
est-ce que le métier de maire est
finalement moins facile qu'avant alors
vous êtes un jeune mare c'est votre
premier mandat mais on a dû vous en
parler à écoutter nos aïux il semblerait
que celuici soit moins facile qu'avant
en tout cas il est très contraint
budgétairement parlant il est très
contraint par des normes par les
tracasseries administratives que
connaissent tous les Français et plus
largement par le fait que nous nous
retrouvons bien seul la porte de la
mairie la dernière porte ouverte de nos
territoires où l'État a fermé les
services public où les usines ont fermé
dans le mépris le plus total et où
seulement le maire a a une oreille
attentive on est à porté d'angulade y
compris pour celle qui ne nous concerne
pas nous sommes souvent les réceptacles
de la colère justifié de nos administré
qui ne comprennent pas j'avais hier dans
mon bureau ou avant-hier ma buraliste
agressée à plusieurs prise et qui voit
dans la rue ses agresseurs sans jamais
être condamnés j'avais il y a peu une
femme seule gagnant le smake qui en
allant travailler a été flashé pour 2
kmh d'excès de vitesse ne pouvant pas
parce que charge d'enfant payer ces
amendes qui se retrouvent aujourd'hui
débitrices de plusieurs centaines
d'euros auprès du Trésor public et puis
tu vois à proximité le trafic a été
déplacé n'est plus dans mon village mais
des dealers roulai dans des voitures
rutilantes et méprisant toutes les
règles de public h et qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui
au au pouvoir public il y a des il y a
des choses qui ont qui ont été fait
Géral Harman a annoncé il y a pas
longtemps des des nouvelles brigades
justement pour ces territoire là alors
il a annoncé 230 brigades dont seulement
en réalité 98 sont des brigades fixes
construit dans des casernes des
gendarmeries les autres ce sont des
espèces de gros camping-cars que l'on
viendra installer de façon régulière sur
les marchés avec des gendarmes qui
rayonneront depuis le camping-car avec
des vélos électriques alors si on pense
un seul instant régler les problèmes de
violence dans la société de trafic de
stupéfiants avec un camping-car sur le
marché je crois qu'on se trompe en tout
cas sur mon marché il n'y a pas de
délincants ils sortent la nuit et mes
administrés ne demandent pas à avoir
entre les poulet rôti et les caisses de
salade les les les gendarmes attendent
et distribuer des prospectus ils les
attendent sur le terrain là où on en a
besoin c'est-à-dire la nuit en zone
périphérique et dans les moments comme
malheureusement à crépool où l'actualité
devient terrible c'est là qu'il faut des
gendarmes c'est pas sur le marché et et
et du coup ça demande plus d'effectif
vous demandez j'imagine plus d'effectifs
dans ces territoire queutes au-delà de
ça on demande simplement la même équité
de traitement avec nos concitoyens
urbain je on n'est pas moins français à
saint-joire qu'on l'est à Paris et quand
on parle des territoires perdus de la
République par exemple à Saint sainten
bien je crois que la présence policière
en saint saint est deux fois supérieure
à la présence de de gendarmes dans ma
commune donc les vrais territoires
oubliés de la République les vrais
territoires perdus ce sont les
territoires ruraux et il est urgent que
l'État et que nos élus nationaux se
saisissent de cette problématique et et
et vous en parlez aussi vous vous aviez
pourtant des postes vacants de gendarmes
donc même si quand il y a des postes les
gens veulent pas forcément venir alors
c'est c'est simplement que les gendarmes
n'ont pas les ressources pour pourvoir
les postes vacants et on ne peut pas
d'un côté créer des zones de des
quartiers de reconquête républicaines
avec de nouveaux postes pour voir créer
de nouvelles gendarmeries et en
simultané remplir les postes vacans dans
les gendarmeries existantes donc avant
d'en créer des nouvelles peut-être
faudrait-il pour voir l'intégralité des
postes et puis densifier les dispositifs
de gendarmerie sur le territoire alors
on a beaucoup de beaucoup de
commentaires sur la page YouTube et sur
la page et sur le site du Figaro qui
adresse leur code condoléance à la
famille combien de temps encore
allons-nous devoir subir cette
délinquence Antoine Valentin est-ce que
vous cette cette délinquence vous l'avez
vu exploser justement
comme vous l'avez dit je suis un un
jeune mère mais j'ai constaté puisque je
suis enraciné de dans ma commune depuis
des années qu'elle évolue qu'elle
s'intensifie qu'elle se durcifie et donc
oui on fait face à la fois un
ensuvagement c'est-à-dire qu'on a des
délinquants qui méprisent les lois de la
République mais plus largement la vie
mais aussi qui peuvent maintenir des
activités criminelles et délinquantes
dans une impunité presque
totale il y a pas longtemps la prison à
côté de chez moi a subi un un grand un
grand contrôle des gendarmes et ils se
sont rendus compte que un chef de clan
albanais continuait de diriger son son
réseau de trafic de stup depuis sa
cellule en prison donc il faut non
seulement des gendarmes non seulement
des moyens de l'État dans les
territoires ruraux mais il faut surtout
une politique pénale qui euh durcifie le
ton et qui euh extraient de la société
les gens qui se comportent de façon
inacceptable et euh j'entendais Dupon
Moretti dire que la justice française
n'avait jamais été aussi dure depuis 20
ans bien euh très souvent mes
administrés constatent qu'elle est dure
avec les faibles et qu'elle est très
faible avec les forts et donc il faut
peut-êtreevir le curseur est aller plus
loin c'est justement vous c'est cette
justice que vous que vous pointez du
doigt la partie policier on comprend et
ça manque de de de d'effectifs il
pourrait y en avoir plus mais ce qui ce
qui vous manque c'est la réponse de la
justice et les deux vont de perd il faut
plus de gendarmes mais il faut surtout
enlever les récidivistes de la rue
puisque les gendarmes 80 % de de de leur
clientèle malheureusement ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui font des
allers-retours en prison quand ce n'est
pas simplement une peine de bracelet ou
ou voir des peines jamais exécuté donc
il faut retirer de la société les
éléments problématiques les punir de
façon drastique faire des exemples on
est capable de le faire avec des chefs
d'entreprise qui feront de l'Ursa full
fisque bien il faut être capable de le
faire de la même façon avec des
délinquants c'est protagoniste de cette
affaire en tout cas les les agresseurs
on les a retrouvé à Toulouse h parce
qu'ils partaient en cavale une cavale ça
coûte cher ça s'organise c'est pas
monsieur et madame tout le monde qui
part en cavale quand il fait une
connerie ce sont des délinquants
chevrenés qui partent avec de l'argent
qui partent avec des réseaux qui partent
en sachant comment fonctionne le système
et qu'il le qu'il le truque qu'il le
détourne et c'est très grave on a une
grande majorité de la société qui est
silencieuse qui respecte les lois de la
République et qui voit le système
s'effondré scolaire santé sécurité et
puis on a une autre partie qui méprise
tout et qui profite de tout et qui
aujourd'hui nous nous conduit dans des
situations qui qui sont insupportables h
et et ça justement vous vos administrés
vous le disent cela tous les jours tous
les jours et et on est à porté
d'engueulade on est au chevet de nos
administrés au quotidien et il y a un
fort ressentiment qui se crée en France
et je vais même au-delà de ça on va
arriver à mon grand regret et il faut
tout faire pour l'éviter à une société
où les gens préféreront se faire justice
même en voyant que la violence légitime
de l'État ne fait plus peur à personne
parce qu'on en est là et et ça sera la
fin de l'État de droit et c'est très
grave et on est en train de toucher le
fond de la piscine et il est temps que
nos gouvernant que nos ministres cessent
les automontades et les effets d'annonce
mais se concentre sur une résolution
réelle des problématiques notamment de
sécurité et d'injustice alors on a James
qui est dans les commentaires qui est
d'accord avec vous c'est bien
d'augmenter le nombre de gendarmes mais
il faut que la justice suive lapp'est
justuse que si est intraitable avec la
délinquence récurrente vous le disiez
tout à l'heure des des des gens vous
parlez de votre buraliste qui qui qui
revoyit les gens qu'il avait braqué
juste avant exactement qu' l'avait
agressé et et c'est c'est
quotidiennement moi un soir j'ai été je
suis tombé sur une femme battue qui
s'était réfugiée devant la mairie j'ai
appelé les gendarmes et nousous sommes
rendus avec les gendarmes à son domicile
pour récupérer son enfant son mari était
sorti de prison le matin même il était
encore sous bracelet judiciire hier il
venait de frapper sa femme il a
abondamment menacé les gendarmes il
était ivre et on l'a retrouvé au beau
milieu de la place du village voilà la
réalité de la délinquence ce sont des
gens qui n'ont plus peur de rien et ces
agresseurs du malheureux Thomas ce sont
des gens qui n'ont plus peur de rien
notre justice nos gendarmes notre
système l'État en général ne leur fait
plus peur ils méprisent non seulement
nos règles ils méprise les valeurs
fondamentales de la société il méprise
la vie il faut une réponse ferme
alors on va retourner dans dans ce
cortège à à ruriser on va retrouver
Timothé dellem qui est notre envoyé
spécial là-bas Timoté comment se passe
cette marche blanche on imagine beaucoup
d'émotions
oui Vincent énormément énormément
d'émotion comme vous l'imaginez on le
disait tout à l'heure des des visages
fermés certains également des yeux des
yeux rouges aussi par moment on a vu
notamment des des des rugbyman qui sont
qui sont venus pour rendre hommage à
leur à leurs camarades qui jouaient au
rugby au stade Albert Donadieu ici à
Roman suriser le stade Albert Donadieu
c'est là où nous sommes en train de de
nous rendre à l'instant il reste encore
il reste encore de longues minutes de
marche mais c'est en tout cas la la
destination finale de cette de cette
marche blanche on nous dit ici
d'ailleurs qu'un mot devrait être
devrait être dit devrait être prononcé
par un membre de de l'équipe de rugby
dans laquelle évoluait Thomas un mot
évidemment dommage pour ce ce jeune
homme décédé samedi dernier et cette
marche qui est donc en train de se
dérouler dans un calme absolu je sais
pas si c'est quelque chose que vous
percevez que vous percevez bien mais ici
en tout cas c'est assez saisissant un
grand grand silence les les personnes
qui qui sont vraiment dans une
atmosphère euh voilà très très calme
avec une une présence policière qui se
fait très discrète également euh et
cette marche qui est en train donc de de
continuer vous le voyez aussi
certainement sur sur ces images euh
toute génération sont sont là sont
représenté toutes les générations sont
représentées il y a évidemment euh des
des jeunes gens du du collège du collège
lycée Donadieu euh où où où le jeune
Thomas était scolarisé et puis et puis
des des personnes un peu plus un peu
plus âgés qui sont qui sont là également
pour pour lui rendre
hommage
merci Timothé on va laisser vivre ces
ces images pour que vous puissiez vous
rendre compte de l'ambiance qui règne
là-bas
et donc vous voyez cette cette marche
blanche qui continue pour qui est partie
du lye de Thomas qui va maintenant qui
prend la direction comme Timothé vous
l'a dit qui prend la direction du club
de rugby où il était licencier ce ce
jeune homme de de de 16 ans qui a perdu
la vie je suis toujours avec Antoine
Valentin mère de saint-jir merci en tout
cas d'être avec nous est-ce que
aujourd'hui on se dit que que être maire
est le est toujours un beau métier en
tout cas qu quand on sait que beaucoup
de beaucoup de de mères beaucoup de
mairies ne trouvent pas preneur
finalement c'est le plus beau des
métiers du monde et quand vous voyez ces
images de de gens qui défilent qui sont
ces Français silencieux qui travaill
payent leurs impôts s'arrête lors d'un
contrôle routier et sont au final des
citoyens exemplaires et bien être maère
c'est les défendre c'est être à côté
d'eux au quotidien et donc oui c'est je
crois une noble mission et et
certainement le plus beau des mandats de
la République à la fois parce qu'il est
concret parce qu'il est sincère et parce
qu'il est enraciné en est dans la
réalité des territoires donc oui c'est
un très beau métier alors dans dans les
commentaires beaucoup de gens parlent de
de cette marche une marche plein de
plein de dignité beaucoup de gens qui
adressent leur le leurs condoléan à
Thomas et à sa
famille forcément est-ce que vous avez
l'impression il y a le Congrès des mères
de France en ce moment est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que en tout cas le
gouvernement vous entend lors de ce
congrès sur des thèmes comme ceci le le
gouvernement ne nous entend pas et cela
fait des années la pruve en présid
président de la République n'a pas
daigné venir à notre congrès il a
préféré inviter 1000 maires alors
étonnamment ils sont très bien choisis à
l'Élysée préférant à la confrontation
républicaine avec les maires de France à
un cocktail avec 1000 maires choisis
c'est le monarque jupitérien qui invite
le temps d'une soirée ses guux au palais
c'est assez insupportable c'est un un
mépris généralisé mais qui n'est pas que
le nôtre qui est plus largement un
mépris de ce que nous représentons la
France des territoires des petites bgade
des périphéries de ville de la France
oubliée donc il n'y a là je crois rien
d'étonnant bien malheureusement vous
vous sentez vraiment oublier vous vous
le disez depuis le début de ce live vous
sentez vraiment oublié de la République
par rapport au voilà aux effectifs de
gendarmerie comme vous le disiez
effectif de gendarmerie mais pas que
service public investissement intérêt
politique je vois pas de de sportif de
haut niveau à cette marche sa travoré
n'est pas là la France insoumise non
plus les députés n'ont pas pas fait de
minutes de silence à l'Assemblée
nationale et pour la simple et bonne
raison que on parle là de la France
silencieuse la France rurale et qu'au
fond et bien c'est pas très important en
tout cas c'est pas très grave ou c'est
moins grave et ça en devient
insupportable c'est le délitement de la
nation on a d'un côté la mort tragique
du jeune Naël suite à un refus
d'obtempérer une course poursuite qui
crée les mois sociétal et puis on a la
mort d'un jeune du même âge inconnu des
services de police enraciné dans sa
commune joueur de rugby qui n'a fait que
d'aller au bal de son village et qui est
tué par une une hordeune meute de de
brut sauvage pratiquement dans le
l'inintérêt de nos élites politiques
effectivement vous voyez sur ces sur ces
images le les la marche qui se qui se
poursuit sur ce sur cette route on se
rappelle on rappelle on est à roman
surisire une ville qui est qui est à
côté à côté de crépool et justement
c'est aussi c'est c'est ces grandes
villes avec des avec des quartiers
parfois difficiles qui sont à côté de
ces petits villages qui peuvent poser
problème vous connaissez bien justement
cette problématique oui oui moi ma ma
commune est coincée entre deux quartiers
de reconquête républicaine donc
effectivement on on récupère une partie
de la population de ces ces quartiers
qui vient s'installer chez nous pour
uniquement des activités délinquantes
ils viennent pas chercher les charmes de
la ruralité il viennent chercher le
désert sécuritaire alors nous on a pu y
palier avec des caméras avec des
policiers municipaux mais c'est pas le
cas de toutes les communes de France
dont les budgets sont en baisse et qui
ne peuvent pas forcément faire face à
cette problématique moi je le vois bien
euh on a eu une action très efficace sur
le terrain mais on a simplement repoussé
le trafic et cette population délincante
vers d'autres communes du secteur h oui
c'est c'est ces caméras de surveillance
et c'est ces effectifs de gendarmerie ça
a eu un effet concret ça ça a un effet
concret ça coûte très cher mais ça un
vrai effet concret ça marche très bien
on a réduit de 80 % le nombre de
cambriolage on on on est prés prés sur
le terrain en permanence mais ça ne
règle pas le fond du problème qui est
l'absence de réponse pénale et notre
incapacité sociétal à mettre hors d'état
de nuire ceux qui méprisent nos règles
nos lois et nos valeurs très bien merci
beaucoup Antoine Valentin en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous maire de maire de
saintjoire je je le rappelle nous allons
maintenant retourner du côté de roman
surizer de cette marche et vous êes nous
allons continuer à vous faire suivre
cette marche blanche merci beaucoup une
nouvelle fois d'avoir été a
vive émotion ici à à roman sur réserve
vous le voyez plusieurs centaines de
personnes sont toujours en train de de
marcher en direction de ce stade Albert
Donadieu pour cette cette marche blanche
en hommage à à Thomas décédé dans la
nuit de samedi à à dimanche vous le
voyez toutes les générations qui sont
qui sont présentes ici certains étud
udan du du lycée dans lequel il étudiait
euh beaucoup également de de de
personnes un peu plus un peu plus âgées
euh je vais vous montrer sur ce sur ce
panneau voilà pour vous vous donner
vraiment une idée de de l'ampleur de
cette mobilisation euh voilà vous voyez
cette cette longue longue marche qui
s'étend jusqu'à jusqu'à loin là-bas euh
à l'entrée au début de au début de ce
cortège avec où se trouent certains
membres évidemment de la famille de
Thomas mais également des membres de son
club de rugby le club de rugby dans
lequel il il évoluait voilà j'essaie de
de vous montrer bien précisément ce qui
se passe ici vous le voyez également des
des roses blanches ici beaucoup de
personnes qui sont venu pour pour rendre
cette cet hommage donc à à Thomas on va
essayer de d'en interroger quelques-uns
je vous cache pas que c'est pas tâche
facile parce que c'est un moment
particulièrement émouvant et les les les
plusieurs personnes à qui j'ai pu m
n'ont pas souhaité prendre la parole
face face caméra évidemment parce qu'il
y a beaucoup d'émotions comme comme vous
l'imaginez cette marche donc qui qui se
poursuit dans un calme
absolu on a du mal à à imaginer ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé samedi
dernier quand on voit cette ce grand
grand élan de de solidarité ici envers
la la famille de Thomas qui est
rappelonsle à l'origine de cette de
cette marche
ça pass à
la N
plusc
[Musique]
voilà la marche qui se poursuit ici à
Roman surivver vous le voyez sur ces sur
ces images nous sommes en train de de
nous approcher de ce de ce stade le
fameux stade dans lequel dans lequel
jouit dans lequel Thomas jouait au au
rugby vous allez le voir là-bas à
quelques à quelques mètre de moi on
commence à à l'apercevoir nous sommes
actuellement sur le parking du du stade
un stade que que Thomas a fréquenté
encore très récemment puisque il était
membre actif de de ce club de de rugby
et les personnes qui sont qui sont donc
en train et bien de de prendre place un
petit peu tout autour de de ce stade le
long des le long des grilles on est en
train de se rapprocher vous distinguez
peut-être là-bas les les ses grands ses
grands poteaux d'ambut euh voilà c'est
ici que que la marche va prendre fin
elle va laisser place à une cérémonie
dommage
je rappelle comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure que un membre de du club de
rugby devrait prendre la parole on ne
sait pas encore si ce sera le cas
également de d'un ou de plusieurs
membres de de sa famille on nous dit
également que des des ballons blancs
devrait être distribué et puis lancé
dans dans le ciel en hommage toujours à
à ce jeune à ce jeune Thomas et comme
vous le voyez beaucoup de beaucoup de
monde il y a du monde ici il y a du
monde également un petit peu plus loin
là-bas on essaie de de prendre place
tout autour tout autour de ce stade
alors que je commence à à apercevoir ces
ces fameux ballons blancs dont je vous
parler à l'instant je vais essayer de
vous les de vous les montrer à à
l'antenne
euh on est en train en fait de de faire
le tour de ce stade et de de nous
diriger vers l'entrée l'entrée du stade
le stade sur lequel se trouve déjà
plusieurs centaines de personnes vous le
voyez juste ici
bonjourar ah oui on aimerait mieux être
oui ça me fait plaisir de
voir
coniss
je ah je vois
ah
ouaère
ou
merci
oui vous voyez l'émotion lors de cette
marche blanche pour Thomas qui a lieu à
Roman suriser des prises de parole sont
prévues on les écoutera tout à l'heure
Pierre Marie Seb directeur d'institud
pour la justice m'a rejoint bonjour
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui on va discuter un peu de
toute cette problématique aujourd'hui
est-ce que déjà vous êtes surpris quand
vous voyez ce ce fait d'hiver qui s'est
déroulé le weekend dernier bah
c'està-dire que on on est surpris j'ai
envie de dire quand on quand on garde un
esprit sa on peut qu'être surpris de se
dire que dans une fête de village le bal
d'hiver d'un petit village de 500
habitants il y a eu 20 blessés des
flaques de sang partout dans la salle
des fêtes et un mort on peut qu'être
surpris maintenant quand on quand on
prend le point de vue d'un
analyste de la justice en ce qui me
concerne et donc de toutes les questions
de sécurité on l'ai moins on l'est
beaucoup moins même on l' même pas du
tout c'est c'est alors beaucoup de gens
l'ont dit mais il y a eu des faits
divers notamment des attaques dans des
fêtes ces derniers mois marcousi par
exemple dans les son des des attaques
plus ou moins gratuites alors le terme
gratuit n'est pas le mieux le plus
approprié puisque aucune attaque n'est
vraiment gratuite en fait on parle
d'attaque gratuite quand on estime quand
l'observateur estime que le motif est
futile là en l'occurrence c'est une
attaque gratuite le motif est futile a
priori être c'est pas encore très clair
hein mais être vexé de ne pas aller dans
une une fête ça ne justifie absolument
pas je pèse mes mots le fait d'attaquer
ensuite et d'attenter au aux personnes
et de s'en prendre à la vie même des
gens donc voilà maintenant cette cette
affaire là elle obéit a beaucoup de
tendances il y a par exemple la tendance
l'attaque dans une dans une
campagne moi je je je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure
mais beaucoup de gens dans les grandes
villes on quand on habite une grande
ville on a le sentiment que on vit avec
dans un coin de notre tête il y a des
endroits en France dans lesquels on peut
vivre sans fermer sa porte à clé il y a
des endroits en France tranquille on
peut aller à la fête on peut laisser nos
enfants aller à la fête du village il va
rien se passer de mal et ben finalement
ces endroitsl sont de moins en moins
nombreux la délinquence dans les
campagnes c'est pas simplement un thème
comme ça qu'on peut brandir c'est une
réalité je vous donne un seul exemple le
nombre de vols de matériel agricole
entre 2016 et 2019 ce sont les derniers
chiffres dont on dispose ça augmenté de
30 %. donc c'est pas simplement quelque
chose en l'air c'est c'est un continuum
de violence qui est partie des grandes
villes qui se développe partout et y
compris la campagne cet ensuvagement
comme l'a dit le ministre de l'Intérieur
déborde de partout h et justement ça se
ça ça se banalise je vous dis dans les
dans les territoires ruraux oui oui oui
alors il y a cette histoire donc de
alors les territoires ruraux tradition
enfin traditionnellement non mais
historiquement depuis une quinzaine ou
une vingtaine d'années ils ont subi
principalement des vols par c'est de la
criminalité organisée ce sont des vols
de matériel des des barrières des des
des des objets métalliques des fils de
cuivre et cetera donc ça on sait que ça
vient de alors attendez juste on entend
en ce moment les avec des ballons qui
viennent d'être lâchés on va écouter ce
qui se passe sur
[Applaudissements]
place
voilà vous venez de vivre ce lâcher de
de ballon blanc qui était prévu à
l'issue de la de la Marche Blanche qui
se déroule en ce moment à roman surizer
nous sommes à l'entrée du du du stade de
de rugby où évoluit le jeune Thomas qui
est
mort Pierre Marie je reviens à ma
question sur cette violence qui se
banalise dans les territis rurau oui
donc historiquement on ait beaucoup de
vol de matériel vol de de céta des ATT
bien par la criminalité organisée dont
on savait qui venait des Balcans
essentiellement dans d'Europe de l'Est
des gangs basés en Moldavie en Roumanie
et cetera les choses ont évolué je
disais une analyse d'un criminologue qui
s'appelle Xavier wofer qui parlait
notamment qui avait fait une
extrapolation sur le vol d'auin donc les
moutons les agneaux et les brebis alors
il a fait une extrapolation à partir des
chiffres d'un département la Loire
Atlantique qui qui avait tiré la
sonnette d'alarme sur ce sujetlà et il
arrivait au chiffre de 40000 auin de
toutes sortes volés chaque année en
France ce sont des millions et des
millions d'euros c'est c'est c'est nos
agriculteurs sont suffisamment mal en
point pour ne pas avoir à subir en plus
des vols d'ovin des vols ces derniers
mois il y a eu aussi toute une affaire
en pareil en Loir atlantique de vol de
de Balis GPS pour les tracteurs ce sont
des du matériel qui coûte beaucoup
d'argent et que témoigner un maire on
volait dans voilà Guerande en Loire
Atlantique et qu'on retrouvait ensuite 3
semaines plus tard à New York euh avir
trafiquer et passer par tout trafic donc
ça c'est encore ça c'est de la violence
ça n'est que matérielle c'est pas aussi
grave que ce qui s'est passé à roman sur
iser mais mais l'autre l'autre vrai
problème c'est que la violence typique
des villes la
violence les atteintes aux personnes là
aussi ça progresse dans les campagnes et
ça progresse même selon les statistiques
du ministère l'intérieur ça
progresserait même plus vite en zone
gendarmerie qu'en zone police la zone
gendarmerie en gros c'est moins de 10
11000 habitants donc c'est la campagne
typiquement euh donc de alors aussi
pareil on sait très bien il y a beaucoup
plus de de fait de violence d'infraction
de CRIM et délit à la ville
traditionnellement vous prenez n'importe
quel chiffre de n'importe quelle
infraction soit les coupes lesessures
volontaires les les violes enfin bref le
nombre de violence par habitant est plus
élevé dans les grandes agglomérations
que dans les petites et c'est logique
vous avez un habitat dispersé dans les
dans les petites villes vous vous avez
un mode de vie plus communautaire
plus voilà il y a plus de personnes
âgées aussi maintenant ça c'est c'est
aussi un fait important dans les
campagne c'est que depuis les années 90
on a une un relatif repeuplement des
campagnes très relatif mais en
particulier de de retraiter beaucoup de
retraités quittent les grandes
agglomérations et vont la campagne et
donc évidemment les retraités commettent
moins de CRIM édali que les plus jeunes
mais donc ça historiquement ça a
toujours été le cas on a toujours eu
plus de violence à la ville qu'à la
campagne mais voir l'écart se serré ça
c'est quelque chose de nouveau c'est
quelque chose d'inquiétant euh et qui
obéit pour moi à une logique en fait qui
est pas tellement spécifique à la
campagne c'est une logique générale je
reprends une nouvelle fois le mot qui a
dit le ministre de l'intérieur
d'ensuvagement on a un ensuvagement
généralisé une augmentation de la
violence généralisée dans la population
c'est symbolisé par un chiffre notamment
une infraction un délit qui les coûpts
et blessures volontaires les coûps et
blessures volontaires ce sont en gros
les agressions et les violences trin fam
FAM et ben l'une comme l'autre les
violences intrafamiliales c'estàd entre
conjoints et cetera et les agressions
sont en hausse depuis depuis 40 ou 50
ans moi les chiffres les plus anciens
que j'ai réussi à obtenir et j'ai posé
une question parlementaire là on a posé
une question parlementaire il y a
quelques semaines sur sur cette question
là mais les chiffres les plus anciens
c'est 1988 où il y avait 40000 coup et
blessures volontaires c'està-dire
agression et d'année en année ça a
augmenté aujourd'hui on est à plus de
300000 c'estàd c'est une augmentation
absolument immense on a bientôt bientôt
FO 7 euh bientôt multiplié par 7 donc
donc donc les coup et blessures
volontaaires typiquement on sait
qu'elles augmentent partout elles
augmentent dans les grandes
agglomérations elles augmentent à Paris
elles augmentent dans les petites villes
et elles augmentent encore plus vite
dans les campagnes h donc alors je vais
je vais redonner juste la la parole à
Timothé Delem qui est sur le terrain
pour qu'il nous livre un peu son son
sentiment qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce
moment sur le terrain vous voyez on voit
vos images toute la foule s'est arrêtée
silencieuse
oui toute la foule silencieuse Vincent
moment de de silence dans le stade je
vous propose de de vivre ce moment
ensemble
encore merci de votreage àain le temps
de
recillement merci de
quitter voilà on vient de l'entendre au
micro les
[Applaudissements]
applaudissements alors BEP beaucoup de
monde vous le voyez ça et forcément ça
capte moins bien pour notre pour notre
journalist qui est qui est qui est sur
place on le retrouvera dans dans un
instant pour qu'il nous raconte un peu
ce qui s'est passé on a entendu cette
voix qui disait c'est la fin de ce
moment de recueillement vous voyez
toujours énormément énormément de
personnes qui sont venues qui sont
présents aujourd'hui à roman sur iser
pour une cette marche blanche pour
Thomas jeune de 16 ans qui a été tué à
créple qui qui jouait au rugby dans ce
club de roman sur iser beaucoup de monde
est est venu lui rendre hommage euh vous
dit disiez sur les sur les sur les sur
les violences volontaires beaucoup plus
c'est ce chiffre augmente alors je dans
les commentaires parfois des gens qui me
disent oui mais est-ce que c'est pas
parce qu'on les comptabilise mieux
qu'avant il y a en partie ça c'est à mon
avis très largement insuffisant euh ça
ne coupe ça ne ne ne remplit pas du tout
l'explication et d'ailleurs ce nombre
très élevé de cou blessur volontaire
nous place la France dans le top 3
européen donc au bout d'un moment moi je
je pense qu' il ne faut pas se cacher
derrière oui on a une meilleure
comptabilisation ça n'explique pas que
la France soit dans le top 3 européen
sur d'ailleurs pass c'est pas uniquement
sur les couples volontaire c'est sur les
vols avec violence c'est sur beaucoup
d'infractions la France est toujours
dans les premiers pays européens alors
que alors que justement la France a plus
de campagne que beaucoup d'autres pays
européens et la campagne normalement
tire à la baisse les statistiques donc
une fois de plus on fait le lien il y a
un changement de paradigme justement oui
B alors oui oui moi vous savez en fait
je pense que cette affaire vous
connaissez vous avez entendu
certainement parler du livre de Jérôme
Fourquet l'archipel français pour moi
cette ce fait d'hiver là montre que la
France qui est un archipel a des îles
entre elles qui se qui s'attaquent les
unes les autres on l'a vu on peut quand
même pas faire l'impasse sur les mots
qui ont été entendés entendus les
témoignages qui disent qu'on a voulu
planter du blanc planter des blancs
quand on entend salale blanc sur des
vidéos euh il y a il y a quand même une
dimension comme ça c'est certainement
pas la
seule je j'imagine que ça n'est pas le
seul motif mais CEN est un visiblement
important et et pour moi donc nous
sommes donc dans des archipeles c'est
exactement ce que décrivait Jérôme
fourqu nous n'avons plus de culture
commune nous n'avons plus les mêmes
prénoms c'était essentiellement ça sur
ça que portait son étude et nous n'avons
plus les mêmes code nous n'avons plus
les mêmes coutumes nous n'avons même
plus les mêmes lois euh puisque la loi
dans la loi dans une je prends l'exemple
d'une cité la loi dans une cité n'est
pas la même que la loi enfin
conceptuellement parlant si vous voulez
euh je prends toujours ce même exemple
le le mariage homosexuel par exemple
quand il a été voté en 2012 2013 par
François Hollande moi je peux vous dire
marage homosexuel n'est pas légal dans
toute la France il y a beaucoup de zones
de non droit où ça n'est pas légal où
vous ne pouvez pas évidemment selon la
loi vous pourrez mais pratiquement vous
ne le pourrez pas ne serait-ce que si
vous venez d'une famille enfin bref donc
et je prends cet exemple là mais il y en
a plein plein plein et la violence en
groupe donner des coups de couteau il y
a des endroits de France où on considère
que c'est illégal j'imagine que dans
l'courage l'entourage de Thomas et dans
l'entourage la plupart d'entre nous et
des auditeurs c'est illégal d'attaquer
quelqu'un en couteau mais chez certaines
personnes c'est moins illégal que chez
d'autres et donc cette coexistence d'un
vrai archipel français où nous où nous
essayons tant bien que mal de de
coexister mais avec des codes chacun
différents fait que ça arrive un combo
destructeur meurtrier sanguinaire de
temps en temps et si on fait un petit
peu ce prospective si je reviens sur les
campagnes il y a un point quand même que
que dont j'aimerais parler c'est les
Jeux Olympiques 202 vous vous souvenez
que les Jeux Olympiques 2024 on nous a
annoncé que Paris allait concentrer une
immense partie des forces de l'ordre une
immense partie des forces de gendarmerie
et de police ça ça vous inquiète ça ça
m'inquiète je suis pas le seul que ça
inquiète beaucoup de M tirent la
sonnette d'alarme là-dessus qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire dans les campagnes on
peut s'attendre à ce que l'été en plus
l'été c'est la période dans laquelle il
y a le plus de CRIM et de délit cet été
l'été 2024 dans les campagnes il y ait
une multiplication une augmentation
sensible du nombre de de de de CRIM et
délit qui se sont déroulés comme
celui-ci et ça oublie d'ailleurs encore
une fois une nouvelle logique qui est on
ne peut on peu plus évidente que Paris
concentre l'essentiel des moyens de
l'État et c'est vécu comme une injustice
à juste titre par la plupart la grande
majorité des autres Français tous ceux
qui n'habitent pas en agglomération
parisienne c'est-à-dire la grande
majorité et là en l'occurrence bah une
nouvelle fois pour les Jeux Olympique
2024 Paris va attirer toutes les forces
de l'ordre au détriment du reste de la
France qui va se retrouver de plus en
plus seul face au criminels au
délinquants oui nous étions avec Antoine
Valentin mère divivers droite du petit
village de de saintjoir qui n disait que
lui il avait un gendarme pour 1300
habitants alors que normalement c'est
plutôt autour de 300 400 dans les dans
les grandes agglomérations ouais mais
vous savez que sur allez sur les sur les
15 dernières années on a dû fermer on a
fermé plusieurs centaines de gendarmerie
de brigades de gendarmerie au moins 500
entre 2007 et 2016 il y a eu 500
brigades de gendarmie qui ont été fermé
entre 2017 et cette année il y en a
certainement encore plus on n pas les
chiffres euh donc au aujourd'hui min
inérieur annonce la création de
nouvelles brigades de 200 nouvell brigad
200 nouvelles brigades mais ça ne
rattrape absolument pas tout ce qui a
été fait depuis 2007 tout ce qui a été
perdu depuis 2007 et donc un habitant
d'une zone rurale en 2007 était mieux
protégé qu'il ne le sera demain malgré
c'est un effort notable dont il faut
tout de même se féliciter l'ouverture de
nouvelle brigade de gendarmerie c'est
sûr que c'est positif mais ça n'est pas
suffisant qu'est-ce que le qu'est-ce que
le gouvernement doit doit faire alors et
bien moi je vous savez les les problèmes
de criminalité qu'on parle de trafic de
drogue qu'on parle de là une attaque
comme celle-ci dans les campagnes et
cetera tous ces problèmes là sont très
divers mais en réalité les solutions
sont assez simples et assez uniques et
la principale solution c'est la justice
la justice est un mécanisme de
régulation sociale al je vous propose
qu'on en parle tout de suite après mais
d'abord je voudrais aller voir Timothé
sur le terrain qui est
avec quelqu'un bonjour Timothé est-ce
que vous m'entendez et vous êtes donc
avec
quelqu'un absolument Vincent je suis
avec avec Anatole qui est étudiant lui
aussi au au lycée du dauphinet en classe
de terminale et il a tenu à à venir
aujourd'hui pour rendre hommage à à
Thomas c'était important pour vous de
d'être présent aujourd'hui bah c
important parce que ce qui s'est passé à
crpol et tout c'est c'est très
grave qu'est-ce que vous retenez de la
personnalité de de Thomas ici la la
plupart des gens avec qui on discute
disent que c'était quelqu'un de
particulièrement attachant ouais c'était
il était très attachant il était
incroyable comment avez-vous réagi à ce
qui s'est passé à ce qui s'est passé
samedi je pense par exemple à à
l'atmosphère qui doit être assez
particulière dans votre salle de classe
en ce moment ouais c'est c'était un peu
très très grave et ouais ça
c'est il y a pas de mot c'est horrible
et que vous disent par exemple vos vos
amis vos le corps enseignant vos
professeurs après après ce qui s'est
passé B il nous dit courage à vous bon
courage et
tout est-ce que comment est-ce que vous
vous envisagez également les les jours à
venir il y a cet hommage aujourd'hui
comment allez-vous faire pour et bien
garder quelque part la mémoire de de
Thomas dans les dans les jours dans les
semaines et dans les années à venir bah
même s'il est plus là dans notre monde
il sera toujours là dans notre cœur
merci beaucoup voilà donc qui est
étudiant en terminale en terminale où
était étudiant également également
Thomas qui est donc décédé samedi
dernier si Timothé on comprend bien
l'émotion qui saisit cette cet élève de
de terminal tout comme l'était Thomas
nous sommes donc à l'issue de cette
marche blanche on on on on parlait
justement avec Pierre Marie SEV
directeur de l'Institut pour la Justice
des solution que le gouvernement
pourrait apporter alors pour moi la
solution à la à toute criminalité à tout
la criminalité est un comportement
déviant est un comportement antisocial
et la solution à tout comportement
déviant ou antisocial c'est c'est la
réponse qu'on que la société va lui
apporter et la justice est un mécanisme
de régulation sociale ça n'est pas
grandchose d'autre finalement quand vous
voulez décourager un comportement la
justice va être plus ferme quand vous
voulez l'encourager ben la justice va
être moins ferme et bien en l'occurrence
si on veut décourager les violences il
faut que la justice soit ferme et c'est
tout le contraire aujourd'hui tant dans
le prononcer des peines puisque je le
rappelle depuis 1994 il n'y a plus
aucune peine minim aucune peine planchée
contrairement à la plupart des pays
d'Europe où il y a encore des peines
minimales et des peines planchées et
depuis depuis les années 2000 l'autre
donc pointoncer les peines je vous l'ai
dit l'autre point qui a vraiment
vraiment perdu et été affaibli depuis
les années 2000 c'est l'exécution des
peines l'Intitut pour la justice nous
avons sorti une étude en début d'année
2023 dans le Figaro d'ailleurs dans
laquelle nous évoquions le chiffre de 41
% des personnes qui sont condamnées à de
la prison ferme et il faut le vouloir je
vais vous dire pour être de la prison
ferme pour connaître un petit peu les
tribunaux euh normalement c'est pas
votre première altercation avec la
justice c'est plutôt votre 3e votre 4e
votre 5e votre 6e alors comment on
explique ce ce chiffre de 41 %. et ben
41 % des condamnés à la prise en ferme
ne rentent jamais en prison et bien
c'est tout simple c'est que dans le code
pénal et dans le code de procédure
pénale il existe tout un tas de
procédures automatiques les juges n'ont
à peine leur mot à dire automatique qui
permettent de transformer une peine de
prison en peine de brasse électronique
en peine alternative ou en peine en
peine aménager donc et et qu'on le
veuille ou non une peine sous brass
électronique ça n'est pas aussi
dissuasif ça n'est pas aussi dissuasif à
l'égard des autres et ça n'est pas aussi
frappant à l'égard de du coupable qu'une
peine embrasse électronique où ils
peuvent sortir la journée quand il quand
il rentent pas à l'heure le soir il faut
il faut au moins 5 soirs de suite sans
être rentré à l'heure pour avoir un coup
de téléphone des services donc vous
m'excuserez mais ça n'est pas une
justice ferme et donc voilà moi pour moi
ça semble assez évident qu'il faut
réécrire le code pénal pour y remettre
des peines minimales euh je reprends un
terme qui a été réutilisé plusieurs fois
là ces derniers jours une révolution
pénale moi c'est ce que je dis depuis
des mois et des années il faut une
révolution pénale on ne s'en sortira pas
avec de simples réformes pénales h on va
retourner sur le sur le terrain avec
Timothé dellem qui est avec un
participant à cette marche Timothé
est-ce que vous nous entendez
oui tout à fait Vincent je vous entends
très bien je suis effectivement avec
avec un participant à cette marche un
participant qui était encore vendredi
dernier avec les grands-parents de de
Thomas qu'il connaît bien et vous me
confiez l'attachement que vous avez pour
pour cette famille absolument oui c'est
une famille que je connais depuis très
longtemps euh son grand-père ben j'ai
travaillé pendant 20 ans avec lui c'est
des gens simples c'est des gens gentils
et toute l'équipe de la banque où on
travaillait est ici présente et
complètement anéantie parce que qui
s'est
passé on ne comprend pas on est dans
l'émotion et je suis très heureux très
très heureux qu' a autant de monde cet
après-midi à roman pour manifester
simplement notre soutien dans cette
marche blanche votre votre soutien à la
famille vous qui connaissiez bien la
famille quel quel genre d'enfant était
Thomas ah Thomas c'était quelqu'un de
patent c'est un rugbyon dans dans l'âme
d'ailleurs on est juste à côté du stade
par ailleurs ses parents étaient
restaurateurs sont toujours restaurate
d'ailleurs et il venait souvent au
restaurant de ses parents jovial et puis
aimé de tous ces de tous ces copains
vous avez d'ailleurs pu voir constater
que toute l'équipe tout le Rugby Club de
roman P péage est là avec des T-Shirts à
son effégie je crois qu'il laisse un
grand grand grand vide non seulement
pour les parents les grands-parents les
amis et puis tous ses collègues du lycée
et du rugby vous avez peut-être un
souvenir une anecdote qui vous revient
en tête au moment d'évoquer la la
personnalité de de Thomas alors pas
spécialement parce que je l'ai pas trop
connu moi je connais plus les
grands-parents vu mon âge et puis les
parents ceci dit je pense qu'il
ressemble et au grand-père et au père
c'était quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti lorsque
vous avez appris ce qu'il s'est passé ce
drame dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
benah écoutez je suis resté scotché
puisque j'étais avec le grand-père le
vendredi c'est-à-dire la veille de ce
qui s'est passé et je dois avouer que
depuis ce temps-là je suis un peu
scotché devant les les informations avec
de l'incompréhension complète euh je ne
comprends pas comment on peut commettre
de tels actes euh dans dans le pays qui
est le nôtre surtout dans des communes
aussi où il fait bon vivre c'est tout de
la de la tristesse on sent peut-être
également une pointe de colère
également je suis effectivement très en
colère euh parce que aujourd'hui euh je
pense que je pense que le gouvernement
ne prend pas euh des décisions qui
s'imposent euh voilà et ce dont j'ai
peur c'est qu'en fait et bien on arrive
à se faire la police nous-même dans ce
domaine là donc ça serait quand même
dommageable et j'espère que le
gouvernement fera en sorte peut-être
d'aller un petit peu plus loin dans tout
ce qui
est tout ce qui est méfit même
même tout début parce que ça commence
comme
ça j'habite pas très loin de la monnaie
le quartier qui est cité en référence je
dois vous avouer que c'est très facile
de constater sur des journaux locaux que
une fois ou deux fois par semaine bien
la les les les gendarmes les policiers
plutôt et les et
les et et puis le le service les
pompiers se font
caillasser ils sont attendus par des
jeunes qui commettent ce méfit là alors
il n'y a pas de blessé ça fait juste une
petite ligne un tout petit encart dans
le journal puis voilà mais ça se
renouvelle c'est un petit peu dommage à
un moment donné où on devrait vivre en
parfaite harmonie d'avoir des choses
comme ça une personne avec qui je je
discutais tout à l'heure un chauffeur de
taxi précisément me disait nous le
quartier de la monnaie à partir de 17h
quand il fait nuit on y va pas parce que
ça craint trop alors vous n'êtes pas
chauffeur de taxi évidemment mais est-ce
que c'est quelque chose que que vous
confirmez ça ah mais je vous le confirme
les é oui bien sûr bien sûr il y a pas
de souci de toute façon c'est une zone
de non droit là-bas on on moi j'ai des
petits enfants j'ai des enfants surtout
des petits- enfants je leur interdis
d'aller là-bas tout seul c'est clair
c'est clair quand vous pensez que les
restaurateurs en limite de de ce
quartier se font caillasser
régulièrement qui quittent le quartier
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus supporter
d'être
caillassé ça prouve effectivement que
aujourd'hui bon nombre de personnes ne
veulent plus aller dans ce Cartier
vous disiez tout à l'heure certaines
personnes ici ont envie de de se faire
justice eu même parce que on voit bien
que le système est à bout de souffle ça
c'est quelque chose que que vous
ressentez les les gens ici ont envie ont
envie de se faire justi même non ils ont
peut-être pas forcément envie ce que je
veux dire simplement c'est que devant
des actes comme ça il est évident que
certaines
réflexions surgissent en disant on va
pas non plus laisser faire totalement
donc voilà mais dans des balles comme il
s'est passé
euh ce qui est un petit peu dommage
c'est que de la part des des parents qui
disent mais à juste titre qui disent
comment ça se fait ils ont pas pu se
défendre ils ont rien fait alors bon
qu'est-ce qu'il faut aller il faut aller
il où il faut aller jusqu'où il faut
aller voilà vous habitez ici roman
suriser depuis depuis de nombreuses
années roman suriser qui étit déjà le le
théâtre de de violence lors des émeutes
l'été dernier qui avait également et
bien subi un attentat en en en 2020
c'est un climat que vous avez vu se se
détériorer année après année ah je pense
qu'effectivement ça il y a une
détérioration petit à petit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il faut faire très attention
quand vous dites un mot de trop ou à
quelqu'un qui a mal garé ou des choses
comme ça euh et bien il y a des
injectives importantes on on on n plus à
l'abri de de se faire traiter alors
quand on devient un peu plus âgé bah on
dit mais où où va-t-on où va-t-on sur un
sur un plan plus personnel vous êtes
proche de la famille Thomas comment
allez-vous manifester votre votre
soutien parce qu'il y a effectivement
cette marche blanche aujourd'hui mais
également il va y avoir bah dans les
jours dans dans les semaines à venir
peut-être un sentiment de de vide
comment allez-vous vous y prendre pour
tenter de les réconforter benah écoutez
on les connaît suffisamment pour pouvoir
dans les quelques jours qui vont suivre
prendre contact avec eux voir de quelle
façon on peut les aider parler parler et
puis bah en espérant que en espérant que
il surmonte ce problème cette
catastrophe qui est arrivée mais bon on
sera à leur côté et si vous deviez dire
un un dernier mot d'hommage à à Thomas
lequel
serait-il mourir parce qu'on n pas au
bon endroit au bon
moment c'est incompréhensible et
j'espère qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui le garderont en mémoire de façon à
ce que on essae de faire avancer cette
société qui devient qui qui perd la tête
qui perd la tête merci beaucoup pour
pour votre pour votre témoignage voilà
Vincent donc pour ce ce témoignage alors
qu'ici les milliers de personnes
présentes à cette marche blanche sont en
train de de quitter les lieux peu à peu
certains restent également sur place
toujours dans ce dans ce silence avec
vous voyez évidemment une une présence
policière tous ces cette marche qui est
en train de de se terminer dans dans le
silence et dans le calme merci beaucoup
Timothé DLEM d'être avec nous en direct
depuis roman Surer Pierre Marie s
directeur de l'Institut pour la Justice
comment vous réagissez à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre bah vous savez qu moi je je
discute très souvent avec les gens de de
de mon sujet c'est-à-dire la justice et
la la criminalité c'est toujours les
gens ont très bien identifié ce qui ne
va pas ils ont très bien identifié
quelque chose n'allait pas ils ont très
bien identifier ce qui n'allait pas donc
ce discours là moi quand je discute avec
n'importe qui avec mes voisins quand je
vais moi-même à la campagne dans ma
campagne pareil les les gens ils ont pas
ils ont pas besoin d'avoir des
raisonnements très poussés ou d'avoir lu
des livres des manuels en entiers de
criminologie ou de droit pénal pour
comprendre qu'il y a des choses qui ne
vont pas que oui c'est oui comme le
disait le monsieur à l'antenne notre
société perd la tête on est dans un on
on fonce droit vers un nafrage collectif
à mon avis sur toutes ces questionsl et
et j'espère j'espère simplement qu'on y
arrivera pas qu'on va réussir à
redresser la barre avant je ne sais pas
si notre personnel politique et publ de
manière générale sera à la hauteur on
peut avoir des doutes bon parfois il y a
des bonnes surprises mais euh oui oui je
je je reviens aussi cette histoire
d'archipel français je pense que il y a
on l'a dit aussi tout à l'heure mais il
y a un vrai problème lié à l'immigration
l'immigration massive déraisonnée
incontrôlé c'est c'est c'est c'est
vraiment incontrôlé dans le sens où le
le pouvoir politique depuis 19 78 et une
décision du Conseil d'État en en 1978
qui empêchait le gouvernement de réguler
le regroupement familial le gouvernement
donc depuis 1978 le gouvernement ne peut
pas fixer de quotas il ne peut pas dire
qui entre et qui sort de France ça n'est
pas possible il n'a pas le droit de le
dire et il faut que le le pouvoir
exécutif opère une sérieuse reprise en
main à ce
niveau-là bon c'est c'est c'est un très
gros challenge qui se dresse devant nous
j'ose espérer qu'il sera relevé et et et
oui je pense que c'est ce drame est est
clairement lié à des des des des
problématiques d'immigration de justice
on en a
parlé voilà maintenant il faut il faut
garder espoir comme comme toujours c'est
pas en perdant espoir que on va
améliorer la situation qu'est-ce que
risque aujourd'hui les les les
différents suspects qui ont été
interpellés à différents degrés on
imagine puisqu'il y a une personne qui
est suspecté lui d'avoir donné le coup
et l'autre qui ont participé à cette
expisition alors euh alors déjà ça
dépend s'ils sont mineurs ou majeurs
alors j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait
une majorité de majeur pour le coup et
donc à ce moment-là un homicide euh
assorti d'une circonstance aggravante
qui est la bande organisé puisque je
crois que c'est sur ce fondement là que
le procureur les poursuit c'est puni de
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
voilà on sait tous ce que ça veut dire
la perpétuité en France un sociologue
qui l'a démontré hein en toute
objectivité même plutôt dans un sens en
disant c'est bien que la perpétuité ne
soit pas trop longue euh c'est 20 ans en
moyenne la perpétuité en France donc bon
on peut se poser des questions quand
même aussi là-dessus euh donc voilà ce
qui risque euh vous avez parlé de la
complicité en France en droit pénal
français la complicité est punie
potentiellement des même peine que euh
le que le crime lui-même donc aussi la
perpétuité il se trouve que dans les
faêes souvent les cours d'asscise
retiennent des sentences moins graves
pour les pour les complices bon ce qui
peut paraître logique dans la plupart
des cas mais je je vous l'ai dit aussi
il y a la question de l'exécution de la
peine qui se pose derrière vous êtes
conté la perpétuité moi vous savez à
l'Institut pour la Justice j'ai
accompagné on accompagne régulièrement
et on a accompagné une famille de
victimes notamment un un père d'un jeune
homme qui s'appelait
Jérémy qui est décédé à Toulouse en 2011
je crois de mémoire pour avoir pour une
cigarette qu'il n'avait pas voilà il y
avait deux deux personnes qui qui de de
racaille habituel he qui lui ont demandé
des cigarettes qu' n en avait pas et il
s'est pris un coup de couteau il est
mort c'était un étudiant pharmacie à
Toulouse certains d'entre vous s'en
souviennent peut-être moi je me souviens
à l'époque j'étais jeune étudiant à
Toulouse et et les avocats alors les les
criminels ont pris 30 ans et n'ont pas
pris la perpétuité et les avocats ont
dit à ce père de victime qui ensuite
nous en a parlé euh oui mais c'est très
bien qu'il n'it pas pris la perpétuité
c'est bien mieux qu'il ait pris 30 ans
parce que vu l'exécution des peines on
ans plus
effu on effectue plus souvent les 30 ans
alors les 30 ans il va pas faire 30 ans
il va faire peut-être 22 23 mais en
moyenne c'est plus longtemps que la
perpétuité la perpétuité c'est à partir
on peutre libérer des 18 ans donc
perpétuité je vous le dis ce sont des
meurtres en mode organisé ce sont des
crimes particulièrement grave des
homicides accompagnés d'actes de
barbarie et cetera et cetera donc donc
la question de l'exécution des peines se
pose elle est elle est très très
importante et j'aimerais aussi rebondir
sur une phrase qui a dit cette personne
qui était qui é intervieé il a parlé il
il espère que les gens ne se fassent pas
justice eux-mêmes et que c'est c'est et
que c'est ça la crainte qui aujourd'hui
le maire qui était sur le plateau aussi
tout à l'heure nous en a parlé tout à
l'heure c'était vraiment ça ça craintte
aussi mais absolument c'est un sujet
queusi l'Intitut pour la justice on
prévient depuis des années quand la
justice ne fait pas son travail ou même
pire quand les citoyens ont la seule
impression que la justice ne fait pas
son travail moi j'estimee qu'elle ne
fait pas son travail mais même on peut
simplement s'arrêter à l'impression
quand les citoyens n'ont pas confiance
en la justice ils vont vont se faire
justice eux-mêmes pourquoi parce que la
justice conceptuellement préexiste au
système judiciaire c'està-dire que la
justice c'est un droit que tout le monde
a c'est un droit élémentaire de
l'humanité c'est un droit naturel quand
vous vous faites attaquer chez vous ça
n'est que justice que de répondre que de
vous défendre de tirer un coup de fusil
si vous avez peur de qu'on qu'on
s'enprenne à votre vie ça n'est que
justice
et historiquement les citoyens ont
dévolu le droit leur droit à la justice
à un système au système de l'État ça
remonte à loin ça remonte au Moyen-Âge
mais historiquement les gens se
faisaient tous justice eux même la
justice se faisait par vengeance par
vendéat par attaque par attaque
préventive enfin bref c'est surtout pas
un monde dans lequel on veut retourner
mais les les citoyens français ont voulu
sortir de ça au Moyen-Âge en donnant à
l'état le monopole de la justice et
progressivement donc ça c'est c'est fait
très progressivement sur des siècles et
des siècles mais à partir du moment où
les citoyens ont à nouveau perdu
confiance en la justice alors il retour
tourne à cet état originel et je ne
souhaite à personne et personne ne le
souhaite le la personne l'a dit là tout
à l'heure personne ne veut retourner à
cet état original puisque c'est un état
de violence mais au moins c'est une
violence à laquelle on a l'impression
d'avoir une certaine prise et et
malheureusement c'est une tentation
complètement naturelle et il faut que la
justice que les magistrats et que les
responsables politiques en charge de la
Justice a commencé par le Garde des saut
réalise vers quelle extrémité est-ce
qu'on va cette extrémité c'est
l'autodéfense c'est se faire justice
soi-même et je peux vous citer un
exemple dans dans ma ma campagne euh
dans le fin fond de la Bourgogne je me
souviens très bien d'une affaire l'année
dernière où trois jeunes ont voulu alors
c'est très inhabituel là-bas mais ont
voulu faire un rodéo urbain dans le
village qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a
un premier voisin c'est mon nom qui m'a
raconté ça euh on a un premier voisin
qui est descendu qui leur a demandé de
faire moins de bruit bon les jeunes
ntempèent pas et bien il y a un deuxième
moyen voisin qui est descendu il avait
un pistolet une arme de point il les a
visé il a tiré en l'air il les a fait
partir
je n'encourage absolument pas à avoir ce
genre de comportement mais pour vous
dire ça commence déjà et en particulier
à la campagne zone d'habitat dispersé
les policiers ne sont pas là en 3
minutes à la campagne on se fait justice
soi-même donc oui c'est une c'est une
tentation c'est de plus en plus une
réalité combien de personnes est-ce
qu'on entend dire ça combien de
personnes moi je je suis relativement
jeune j'ai pas 30 ans mais autour de moi
mon entourage le nombre de personnes qui
veulent passer leur permis de chasse qui
veulent avoir une licence de tir pour
acheter les armes pour pour défendre
leur famille dans l'éventualité où il y
en aurait besoin se multiplie à vue
d'œil c'est une évidence donc il faut
réaliser que tout ça ce sont des signes
qui ne trompent pas il faut réagir
maintenant il faut que la justice se
reprenne en main maintenant il faut que
les hommes politiques se reprennent en
main maintenant et reprennent en main la
justice maintenant on ne peut plus
attendre et plus on attendra plus la
reprise en main sera difficile voir voir
je veux pas dire le moins possible voir
très difficile il y a aussi une
problématique pour la ville par exemple
de crépool ces villes qui sont des
petites villes à côté de plus grandes
agglomérations où il y a des des
quartiers difficiles ça aussi c'est
c'est c'est une réalité et ça c'est une
c'est une c'est une oui c'est une
réalité j'ai écrit d'ailleurs dans le
Figaro là en début de semaine là-dessus
la loi SRU qui date de décembre 2000
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler ce que c'est
cette oui la loi su est une loi qui
impose dans la quasi totalité des
communes de plus de 3500 habitants
c'est-à dire pas grand-chose 3500
habitants c'est c'est pas c'est pas un
trou mais c'est c'est quand même pas une
très grande ville euh il y en a quand
même partout à travers le territoire il
y en a des milliers des villes de 3500
habitants et plus euh dans donc dans
chaque commune de 3500 habit habitants
et plus il faut 20 % de HLM bah oui mais
20 % de HLM dans dans toutes ces
communesl ça cadrie le territoire de
quartiers à problème les HLM à la base
c'était pour loger les personnes
vulnérables c'est tout à fait noble
c'est tout à fait louable mais c'est
devenu complètement autre chose il y a
un livre référence sur l'HLM qui
s'appelle 40 ans dans les cités euh par
un ancien préfet qui s'appelle Michel
auoin quelqu'un de de de brillant et qui
explique très bien comment la cité sa
propre cité Michel auoin une cité de
Dreux est devenue un lieu où les gens
s'entendaient bien c'était les fils
d'ouvriers français et cetera est devenu
en l'espace de à partir dès les années
80 en tout cas àreux c'est devenu un
lieu d'hébergement temporaires des
immigrés les plus récents et
d'hébergement définitifs des des des
immigrés en tout cas la plupart les plus
criminels et les plus criminogènes
puisque les seuls qui restent dans les
cités ce sont les dealers de drogue et
ceux qui en vivent parce que les cités
pour beaucoup de raisons d'urbanisme et
cetera et géographique ont beaucoup
d'avantages à être un lieu
d'entreoposage de vente de drogue et
d'ailleurs ce sont les seuls qui payent
leur loyer à temp disait Michel auoin
dans son livre donc c'est très
intéressant j'a j'auris une dernière
question pour vous Pierre Marie c'est
l'ambiance qu'on a senti aujourd'hui
comment vous vous l'avez vécu avec cette
foule très nombreuse qui s'est déplacée
à Ran sur iser euh c'est une ambiance
extrêmement lourde ne serait-ce que le
temps donne par une soirée d'hivers de
début d'Hiv Iver en fin d'après-midi où
le le soleil se couche déjà l'ambiance
ass semblée à travers les images est
extrêmement lourde pour avoir fait
d'autres marches blanches je je confirme
que c'est que personne n'a envie de
parler trop fort personne n'a envie de
se faire
remarquer on est tous dans une une même
ambiance il y a aussi ça bon qui qui qui
est rassurant d'un certain côté c'est
que il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens
c'est qu'en fait l'immense majorité des
gens n'aspire qu' a une vie tranquille
pire qu'à vivre leur vie en paix sans se
faire home jacker car jacker pour
prendre des termes
anglais donc bon c'est le côté qui est
rassurant mais il suffit d'une minorité
pour il suffit d'une brindille déposée
dans l'océan pour que
l'océan soit malheureusement
complètement chamboulé du tout au tout
et là c'est ce qui s'est
passé à crpol ce weekend très bien merci
beaucoup pierre mariss d'avoir été avec
nous directeur de l'Institut pour la
Justice on va revenir du du côté de
Timothé Delem qui est sur le terrain
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
peu un bilan de cette marche blanche ce
que vous avez vu l'ambiance on vous
écoute
Timothé voilà vous le voyez hein sur ces
sur ces images derrière moi le derrière
moi c'est le l'entrée ou la sortie du du
stade les les gens qui sont en train de
de partir mais qui prennent qui prennent
leur temps le temps d'être présent le
temps
de rendre hommage à à à Thomas parce que
évidemment dans les dans les jours qui
vont qui vont venir et bien c'est aussi
comme me le disait certaines personnes
qui ne souhaitaient pas parler devant la
la caméra mais qui qui disaent que
effectivement la vie va reprendre son
cours et donc pour eux c'est important
de de rester ici parce que voilà c'est
maintenant que l'on rend hommage à à
Thomas voilà donc les gens qui qui
quittent le stade peu à peu mais voilà
c'est c'est vrai que ça ça ça prend ça
prend son temps ce que l'on retient de
cette de cet après-midi Vincent c'est
d'abord évidemment le monde beaucoup
beaucoup de monde ici évidemment c'est
c'est pas évident de de vous donner un
chiffre à la louche quand on est dans le
cortège mais plusieurs milliers de
personnes ça c'est sûr qui qui sont
présentes aujourd'hui on le disait tout
à l'heure des des personnes de toute
génération qui sont qui sont là on les a
d'ailleurs interroger à à l'antenne et
puis et puis bien sûr cette cette
atmosphère que l'on que l'on retiendra
cette atmosphère qui n'a rien à voir
avec celle que l'on peut retrouver par
exemple sur des sur des manifestations
puisqu'on parle de cortège là on est
vraiment sur une marche
dommage avec un un grand grand silence
pendant toute la durée de de cette
marche certaines personnes qui qui qui
parlaient entre eux mais qui veillaient
à à vraiment parler euh parler vraiment
à voix à voix basse on a entendu tout à
l'heure une marseillaise qui a été qui a
été entonnée également et puis puis et
puis une salve de d'applaudissement au
moment où la la personne du du du stade
de rugby du club de rugby plus
précisément où jouit où jouit Thomas a
terminé son son petit son petit discours
dommage voilà donc ce que l'on retient
beaucoup de monde atmosphère également
atmosphère ici très très recueilli pour
pour cet hommage cet hommage à Thomas et
puis et puis tous ces visages ces
visages assez marqués on a vraiment vu
beaucoup de de personnes avec les avec
les ye rouge et puis on on entend aussi
hein les les conversations ici ou là de
gens qui disent bah voilà ça aurait pu
arriver à n'importe qui ce genre de ce
genre de propos évidemment voilà donc
beaucoup beaucoup de d'émotions cette
cet après-midi
ici merci beaucoup Timothé d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui merci à vous et du
Figaro d'avoir été nombreux à nous
suivre si vous voulez continuer de
suivre l'actualité vous restez bien
évidemment sur le Figaro vous pouvez
retrouver d'illeurs d'ailleurs sur notre
site un article écrit par Rosen morga
qui était tout à l'heure avec nous pour
en début de Live expédition punitive à
crépool le récit de la soirée qui a
coûté la vie à Thomas c'est à retrouver
sur le site du Figaro merci une nouvelle
fois d'avoir été avec nous merci Timothé
Delm qui était sur le terrain Rosen
morga qui était avec nous en début de
Live merci à Vincent rou qui était là en
régie avec nous ainsi que Louis Chabin
nous on vous souhaite une très bonne fin
de journée sur le site du Figaro et sur
Figaro live votre prochain rendez-vous
ce sera à 16h et ce sera la question du
jour bonne soirée sur le
Figaro
est
là
je suis pas le figaron
fait le moment bien gentil mais c'est
pas bon du tout c'est pas le
moment
ad
madussi pour
non